vous savez que j'ai voté pour voir 2012
mais comme je vous dis aux deux tours
même j'ai voté pour vous et de toi oui
mais il faut dire aussi qu'on se
connaissait pas à l'époque c'est vrai ça
aura rien changé du tout j'aurais quand
même voter pour françois sans hésiter je
te remercie ou sans rien à voir avec
tout ça on célèbre jeu trop mignon comme
ouzou où ma famille est droite depuis
les croisades mais moi j'ai toujours été
de gauche c'est comme ça je suis de
gauche parce que parce que je pourrais
pas vous dire ne dit pas là non non mais
ça c'est un poste de l'intérieur j'ai
pas d'explication c'est souvent comme ça
avec les convictions
alors plus c'était génial votre truc du
président normal ça veut absolument rien
dire et en même temps c'est évitant sait
pas rester vide dans très longtemps
et c'est fou ce sens de la répartie
l'air vous devez être redoutable dans
les débats oui oui c'est vrai quand je
discute avec une chèvre j'ai souvent le
dernier mot
[Rires]
et je sens vraiment bien ici
s'il vous plaît monsieur le président à
droite tournée voit un tout petit peu
vers la gauche qu'elle préside
pas vous
je pense que vous avez dit à françois
mais dites vous êtes parler n'est plus
le même homme même dire qu'il n'appelait
de rechute frag
de quoi vous avez parlé tous les deux
tout court n'a pas l'habitude et de
macron ça vous ferait plus rien la
trahison et l'humiliation tout ça un
doute au bon soir
[Musique]
et si t'arrives
me dis pas vous avez reparlé de macron
mais pas du tout
commence à créer un parti
je vois la france pour toujours présent
bonjour à tous bonjour à tous on fait la
campagne et je suis et on est élu et la
démocratie est sauvée voilà en gros
depuis que je suis ici je suis assailli
par des mots et des notes qui me vient
de tous les côtés c'est comme un
bombardement
permanence purquoi oui je comprends pas
je crois qu'il est guéri c'était
président de la république ce n'est pas
une maladie c'est un honneur suprême une
bénédiction des dieux main ça se discute
un nom ça se discute pas
et vraiment bons spots et 1,6 label qui
fait ça les femmes aux fourneaux ça
marche peut-être encore dans votre 16e
arrondissement mais dans la vraie vie on
n'en est plus là
dans mon 16e arrondissement comme vous
dites c'est ni homme ni femme c'est
traiteur
en plus c'était génial vote rue du
président normal ça veut absolument rien
dire et en même temps ces huit ans c'est
pas rester évident très longtemps
nous avons déjà consulté nos amis dérape
et que le d'europe eq lol j arrive
jamais avec leur nom à la con europe
europe europe écologie écologie europe
ecologie les verts europe
et rapide sur le fait exprès non
[Musique]
j'habite à 7,6 me sens bien
[Rires]
[Musique]